[Música]
[Aplausos]
y me le dijo en un momento en el que yo
estaba muy triste y muy decepcionada de
mí
en aquel tiempo yo trabajaba para una de
las imprentas más grandes de la ciudad
el problema de trabajar en una imprenta
es que si cometes un error ese error
se va a imprimir la cantidad del tiraje
de esa publicación
y yo voy a cometido en un error en una
publicación de un tiraje de 50.000
ejemplares
ya lo supere
cuando le platico esto a gabi ella me
dice ay hermana nunca de ser 100
nunca es el ciento
le dije a unos compañeros más tarde
ellos me respondieron con risas y
miradas sorprendidas ellos no entendían
me atrevimiento de decirles que no se
desempeñarán a su máximo potencial
yo me reí con ellos de manera vacía
no sabía que estaba respondiendo una
pregunta que tampoco sabía que tenía
me parece que vivimos en una sociedad
donde la prioridad de ser efectiva y
productiva una sociedad donde debemos
ser competitivos y abrazados donde decir
que siempre estoy ocupada que soy una
guerrera que dormir es para los débiles
todo esto les puedo asegurar les va a
quitar el sueño se van a sentir enfermos
y te vas a cuestionar varias veces si la
versión infantil tuya esperaba esto de
tu versión adulta
me tuve que cuestionar a que me estaba
esclavizado y si esto era lo que yo
quería para mí
hay pocos motivos para ver el zen
uno de ellos es si te gustan los
videojuegos
y es un juego de aventuras y colecciones
aire y objetos sabes que los tienes que
bordar para el final
no vas a usar la espada maestra con
cualquier elfo que se te parezca la vas
a usar con el jefe de nivel 144 para
disfrutar el fuego
otro ejemplo es cuando tenemos un evento
social importante una graduación una
boda nos arreglamos nos compramos ropa
nos gusta vernos de lo mejor las mujeres
vamos al salón a mí me gusta decir que
voy al taller de pintura y enderezado
hacemos lo mejor que podemos para
recordar ese momento
una novia el día de su boda va a dar su
piel y con toda razón porque ese día lo
va a celebrar
a veces la ropa es como una armadura
para nosotros para elevar nuestra
apariencia para dejar una buena
impresión
otro ejemplo puede ser donar un órgano
donar un órgano no es algo fácil lo
hacemos por nuestros seres queridos para
que estén en un tiempo más con nosotros
un ejemplo más puede ser cuando vamos al
concierto de nuestro grupo musical
favorito
durante el evento ellos van a cerrar con
su canción que fue el éxito de su
carrera musical
otro ejemplo más puede ser correr un
maratón
para correr un maratón entrenas con
meses de anticipación
empiezas con distancias cortas y vas
incrementando
empiezas a sacrificar mañanas para
ganarle al sol empiezo a sacrificar
salidas con tus amigos
empecé a sacrificar esos tacos por una
ensalada
ya en el evento
no puedes evitar sentir la adrenalina de
ser parte de eso
pero si entrenas que mínimo ya tienes la
mitad de la distancia en la bolsa no
vamos a arrancar dándolo todo durante 90
el entrenamiento de un maratón no se
recomienda que corra la distancia
completa durante el plan porque
porque el cuerpo le toma de dos a cuatro
semanas recuperarse después de recorrer
una distancia que son 42.195 kilómetros
si hiciéramos esto el plan se se
arruinaría
mientras vas corriendo empiezas a ver
tus pequeñas recompensas
yo puedo decir de aquí a ese poste de
luz
veo por allá que la porra estando gates
y rajas de naranja
ya para el kilómetro 31 32 la cosa se
pone difícil
nos topamos con la famosa pared
la pared para el corredor es un momento
en donde el cuerpo deja de estar
quemando los carbohidratos que
preparamos y empieza a quemar la grasa
tu cuerpo se siente pesado
empiezas a cuestionarte por qué estoy
aquí
y no sabes si quieres ir al baño no
quieres tomar agua
pero para eso te preparaste y para eso
preparaste herramientas que sabes que te
van a dar empujones para llegar hasta el
final estas herramientas pueden ser la
camiseta de tu club con esa frase
motivacional sus calcetines de la suerte
o sácate tu celular
esa playlist que preparaste con las
canciones super secretos tuyas que van a
hacer que llegue hasta el final
yo te puedo compartir una canción de eso
es para mí es la de la película animada
de hércules de cero aire
es importante para nosotros identificar
objetos sonidos o imágenes que nos
ayuden llegar hasta el final que sirven
como empujones esos empujones que nos
ayudan a seguir estudiando a seguir
levantando pesas o a seguir haciendo
cualquier actividad que nos llene el
corazón
para mí estos empujones se traducen en
pensar en mi familia
en mis amigos pensar en ellos hasta que
se me olvide por unos momentos el
malestar y que pueda llegar a esa línea
de meta
vamos a imaginar todos que estamos en un
concurso de talentos
la mejor voz el mejor truco de magia o
la mejor acrobacia
es tu turno me parece de frente a los
jueces
pero sabes que si quieres pasar a la
siguiente ronda no vas a presentar tu
mejor acto
vas a sacar todos los asesinables
necesarios que tengas bajo las mangas
para pasar a las siguientes fases esto
es no dar en 100 es el principio
tenemos que pensar siempre que todo es
posible porque la narrativa de nuestra
vida eso es todo lo que tenemos
cómo vas a ganar este concurso
no lo sé no podemos contar los
acontecimientos que pasan en nuestro
alrededor
lo que sí les puedo decir es que todo lo
que les he dicho hasta ahora son
sugerencias para enfrentar nuevos
proyectos
acompaña tu esperanza de cumplir las
metas con resiliencia la actitud menor
demuestra que a ti ya los jueces porque
estás ahí saca de esa habilidad que
nadie pensó que tenías
porque eso es uno de los mejores
placeres en esta vida
nunca dejes 100 significa dejar lo mejor
de mí para el final
significa una técnica de
autoconocimiento para elevar nuestras
virtudes significa ser una campeona de
resistencia significa elegir el momento
adecuado
en el libro de adén brand
los originales
como los que no se conforman mueven al
mundo
él explica el término de eficiencia y
productividad
dichos términos se puede decir que pobre
nen de la revolución industrial la
revolución industrial fue una etapa de
crecimiento para la humanidad donde la
economía dependía de la tecnología y de
la industria
se puede decir también que la frase del
tiempo es oro proviene de ahí la vida
está en función del trabajo
pero muchísimo tiempo antes en el
antiguo egipto existía el término de
procrastinación
esta palabra se define como el hábito de
aplazar o postergar cosas que tenemos
que atender
en el antiguo egipto le daban dos
significados
un uso que se le atribuyen a la pereza
y el otro se lo atrevían a elegir el
momento adecuado
ellos ya lo sabían
procrastinar puede ser una herramienta
para nosotros para marinar nuestras
ideas
sazonar las y presentar el platillos más
sabrosos de los demás
mi camino para llegar aquí estaba
plagado de momentos donde debo decidir
si debo dar el cien o no
mis 100 de este año es muy diferente al
del año pasado
he tenido que entender
que no soy indispensable para el lugar
de trabajo
que probablemente hay alguien allá
afuera que es mucho más creativa y mucho
más acertada que yo
sin embargo le he hecho ganas a lo que
hago y quiero pensar que es algo difícil
deshacerse de mí
si ha habido momentos donde dicho ok sí
le voy a decir lo voy a hacer todo
este resultado en que he tenido que
alargar ese momento
pero para no colapsar
tengo que empezar primero en mi
bienestar
y si yo no estoy feliz
si mi entorno no está feliz si yo me
siento agobiada
la gente me rebasa de ser agobiada y las
responsabilidades se van a pelear en mi
vida diaria
yo me preocupo pero no me agobio para
poder distinguir donde si debo dar lo
mejor de mí que curiosamente es cuando
hago lo que más me hace feliz
nunca debe ser 100
significa madurar
significa manejar nuestra atención es
para evitar la fatiga
significa dar un paso atrás
respirar hondo
ver nuestra obra de arte y encontrar el
punto enfoque
quiero que recuerden esto por favor
ustedes siempre van a van a decidir
donde cómo por qué y cuándo va a nadar
se siente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]